tonight on the new reality
intermodal facilities are a green game
changer
used to transfer goods between trucks
and trains
there's just one problem with milton
it's the wrong place
some people will say this is nimbyism
right we're not against intermodal but
it does not belong beside residents
[Music]
if you lived through it it's not
something you forget
they called it the crippler my dad
remembered his youth and he was
paralyzed
all down one hand he was blind in one
eye the rest of his life he didn't want
another
child to miss getting the vaccine
he knew what it meant to have polio
hello i'm donna friesen our first story
tonight is about something most of us
take for granted but couldn't function
without
railway lines they crisscrossed this
country and building them more than a
century ago was not just an engineering
feat it was a way to connect the country
and they remain a federal responsibility
so when cn rail proposed a big new
intermodal terminal in milton ontario
people who live there
had little say it's a terminal where
lots of trucks and trains will connect
to carry goods
vital to our consumer driven lives but
for some in milton it's a monstrosity
that will bring
noise choking traffic and dangerous air
pollution
right into their backyards jeff semple
now
on a 20-year fight that's about to reach
its last stop
[Music]
when priscilla burton and her husband
moved to milton
10 years ago they knew this was where
they wanted to raise a family
the community is just an hour's drive
west of toronto
but offers an escape from the big city
perched on the edge of a nature reserve
steps from walking trails and fishing
pods
milton's mix of country and city life
has made it one of canada's youngest
and fastest growing communities milton
was kind of like the perfect mix where
it's like still gta
but like it was we had more access to
like countryside
and farms and conservation areas
and when it comes to her children's
health burton can breathe
a little easier her five-year-old son
sebastian suffers from asthma and this
community
offers a breath of fresh air we're
always outdoors like our kids are really
outdoorsy kids so we're usually always
kind of taking walks along this path
but this family like many others here is
worried
a new neighbor is poised to move in just
down the street
which could carry consequences for their
health
we did come the here for the kids so
that's still kind of one of our major
points so if we kind of start to feel
that it's not a good fit and we're
worried about
what it's going to mean for them go cut
then that might be
the decision to kind of move somewhere
else this community is now
at a crossroads over a fight that's been
gathering steam here for two
decades back in 2000 this stretch of
land
around 1200 acres was quietly acquired
by a century-old corporation
cn the canadian national railway
purchased the property
with plans to build an intermodal
terminal
described in this promotional video
intermodal facilities are a green
game changer used to transfer goods
between
trucks and trains cn says the milton
facility
would reduce greenhouse gas emissions by
eliminating 200 million
kilometers of truck travel every year i
mean imagine how many trucks that would
take to carry that train load of
containers
greg gormick is a rail and
transportation analyst
whose lifelong love affair with trains
runs
in the family four generations of his
relatives have worked on the rails
dating all the way back to cn's
predecessor in 1882
just talking about the railway and its
rich history
makes him emotional oh i'm almost
getting teary
it's the national dream it's what built
canada the intercolonial railway from
halifax to montreal
the canadian pacific the original
western transplant now
you feel like you're part of history um
to know railroaders it's it it's a
family
but gorman now finds himself in a family
feud he's an expert in intermodal
logistics
and worked for cn in 2000 back when it
began purchasing the land in milton
and right from the time cnn announced
its plans gormick
was concerned it's a great idea i fully
support it there's just one problem with
milton
it's the wrong place it shouldn't be
there
cn's promotional video of the intermodal
facility paints
a sunny picture of a seamless supply
chain but the reality
looks more like this
cn's intermodal terminal in the nearby
city of brampton
the facility built in the 1970s is now
nearing capacity
struggling to meet the growing demand
for goods from the greater toronto area
the result a slow seemingly endless
procession
of transport trucks rolling in and out
24 7 365 days a year
[Music]
people have the right to be concerned
about what those emissions those diesel
emissions can do
big picture these intermodal facilities
provide an environmental benefit
by taking long-haul trucks off the road
but anyone living nearby
risks exposure to potentially dangerous
emissions from trucks as well as noise
dust and light pollution that's why most
of these terminals
like the one in brampton are built in
industrial areas
far from residential neighborhoods but
in milton
it's a much different story cn's
proposed site here in milton
sits just across the street from a
sprawling residential area within a
kilometer of
thousands of residents a hospital and a
dozen
schools so this is your property
yes where would the facility be built
right there right across the road rita
vogel post and her family have lived in
milton for 35 years
and she spent the past two decades
fighting the cn proposal
how are you feeling at this moment
exhausted but we haven't given up
vogel post recalls first hearing rumors
that a group of anonymous
numbered companies were buying up the
land across the road
nobody knew who it was then in the
spring of 2001 there was an official
announcement
that cn was proposing to build an
intermodal terminal
and truthfully no clue what an
intermodal terminal is
but the more she learned the more she
worried
the proposed site would see 800
transport trucks
coming in and out of the facility every
day the nearest
non-toll highways are 10 kilometers away
meaning those trucks would roll along
local roads
and residential areas some people will
say this is nimbyism right not in my
backyard absolutely and i can understand
that
we're not against intermodal but let's
be responsible with where we're
placing it it does not belong beside
residents
in response to cn's proposal vogel post
spearheaded a campaign the professional
graphic designer produced and
distributed
these pamphlets hosted rallies and
addressed community meetings
i think they realized that we weren't
just a quiet community that we're going
to roll over and
just let this happen in 2008 facing
widespread community opposition
cn hit the brakes on the intermodal
terminal
and for nearly a decade the proposal and
the property
lay quiet but then in 2015
cn suddenly changed course announcing
its plans for the milton terminal
were back on track and what was the
reaction
people were alarmed and for good reason
the federal government appointed an
independent panel of experts on the
environment and transportation to review
cn's proposal in its 400-page report
the panel found that most of the adverse
environmental effects
are likely to occur whether or not the
project proceeds
because the lands have been designated
for future development
but they concluded the terminal is
likely to cause significant adverse
environmental effects on air quality
and on human health as it relates to air
quality
noting three contaminants in particular
would exceed air quality criteria
one of those by 2 600
all three of these are what we call
known carcinogens in humans
christian larsen is an environmental
health expert who studies canadians
cancer risks these are non-threshold
contaminants so we don't have an
acceptable level we don't know at what
level will you start to have a
health outcome health canada found cn
had not adequately assessed the health
risks from diesel exhaust
and recommended the corporation reduce
emissions of non-threshold contaminants
associated with diesel exhaust i don't
think they've they've done enough to
estimate kind of lifetime exposure
risks like especially related to cancer
considering how close the terminal would
be to homes and schools
the panel also addressed concerns about
cargo
cn says around three percent of the
containers
some twelve thousand per year would
house dangerous goods
such as household cleaning and lawn care
products i mean you've got trains going
through
with things like sulfuric acid but the
panel concluded that the risk of a
serious accident
including a major derailment was low and
intermodal terminals have a strong
safety record
according to transport canada i'm not
wildly concerned about
[Music]
an accident where there's going to be an
explosion or anything i'm more concerned
about the long-term
health effects those lingering health
concerns don't sit well
with residents including milton's mayor
am i about to gamble with a community
no i'm not gord krantz is the longest
serving mayor in
all of canada during his 40 years in
office
he's seen his community transformed from
a small town
to a population of a hundred and forty
thousand
so and again you can see in the distance
there a new
school being built to accommodate that
rapid growth
the city crafted a long-term plan to
build businesses
homes and schools mayor krantz says
cn's intermodal terminal would put those
plans
in jeopardy was cn coming to the table
and asking
if they could do this no they weren't i
would
caption that they were telling us some
of the closest residents will be
probably within yards meters
of this facility cn declined our request
for an interview but in a written
statement the company noted the review
panel found
cn's criteria for site selection were
reasonable
the proposed site could support an
intermodal terminal
and that cn has identified and
considered the effects of alternative
means of carrying out the project
including alternative project locations
it's the average citizen out there and
i'm not just talking about one or two
and i'm talking about the
masses of the people just don't want it
this video is one of several produced by
milton and surrounding communities
opposed to the project
over the last 20 years the region's
political leaders
of all stripes and levels of government
have been
united in their opposition to cn's plan
normally that would be enough to stop a
development in its tracks
but in this case the community doesn't
get
to decide
the rules governing rail companies are
as old
as canada written way back in 1867
the constitution ensured railways were
the domain of the federal government
at a time when their ability to build
and connect the country
was essential to the economy the result
today
while most industries require a
community's approval to build
cn's fate falls to the feds
this could be saskatoon this could be
vancouver
it could be halifax it can be anywhere
there are all these concerns
and i just feel that cnn is part of the
expression railroading this one through
liberal mp and former olympian adam
vancouverdin
won this riding in last year's election
he says the cn proposal was the top
issue
and he's calling on cabinet to side with
his community
they've been loud and clear cn
intermodal just doesn't have a welcome
home here in milton
as always we will move forward in a
responsible way and the trudeau
government has delayed its decision on
the milton terminal
until sometime in december but burton
and her family
aren't waiting around to find out if cn
gets the green light
they're kind of putting their company's
interest ahead of our health and
like the good of our town they're moving
to the other side of the city
further away from the proposed site
obviously we know like milton's a
growing community
there's going to be different things
that come in we know that but it has to
be the right thing at the right place
for it to make sense and this just isn't
coming up on the new reality my dad
remembered his youth
he didn't want another child to miss
getting the vaccine that was one of the
worst things about polio
who it went after mostly children nobody
knew if it was a bad batch
or if in fact there was a problem with
the vaccine
if he had stopped in canada that would
have kept the balance
[Music]
we're all watching and waiting for
scientists to pull off what's never been
done before
creating a safe and effective vaccine
for a coronavirus
one man watching perhaps more closely
than most is a former canadian prime
minister
paul martin had polio as a child before
there was a vaccine
back then polio paralyzed or killed over
half a million people around the world
every year
martin's story is personal it's about
the life-changing impact of a vaccine
but it's also a cautionary tale here's
mike armstrong
if you lived through it it's not
something you forget
polio targeted children it stole lives
the ability to walk even the ability to
breathe
the nickname didn't help either they
called it
the crippler every kid was warned
by his mother and his father one person
who remembers what those years meant
is former prime minister paul martin we
sat down recently
at a safe distance due to covet 19 to
talk about another
virus as a boy growing up in southern
ontario his parents would tell him not
to play around water that could be
contaminated
but the warnings didn't work he was
eight years old when he told his mother
he felt something strange in his stomach
the next thing i knew i was in the car
on the way to hotel do hospital in
windsor there was no
if what's her maze she had been warning
me about polio
ever since i was born and it happened it
was all kids my age
that was one of the worst things about
polio who it went after
mostly children it's a virus spread
usually through contact with infected
fecal matter
in bad cases it infects the spinal cord
and causes paralysis
it can even paralyze muscles around the
lungs
these massive machines helped paralyzed
children breathe
martin remembers when one was wheeled
into his ward an
older boy explained what it was they
brought in an iron lung
i had never seen an iron one but i had
it in the lungs
and i i turned to and i said what's that
and he said that's an iron lung and
that's where you're going to end up
and i got to tell you then i suddenly
realized
what i was in for it's hard to imagine
what parents went through
dropping off their children hoping for
help when there was no cure
if children got better it wasn't much
more than luck but for paul martin's
parents there was a reason for even more
fear
paul martin senior as a boy had polio as
well
my dad remembered his youth and he was
paralyzed
all down one hand he was blind in one
eye the rest of his life he didn't have
any
capacity to use his left arm or his left
shoulder
but as a kid he was his
brothers and sisters used to pull him
around in carts
and he recovered from that and was able
to
he was able to walk in the right way and
lead a fairly productive life and
a fairly productive life the honourable
paul martin secretary of state
paul martin senior is in fact one of the
most accomplished political figures in
canadian history
an mp for 32 years and a cabinet
minister under
four different prime ministers in fact
he was health minister during
canada's worst polio epidemic in 1953
there were 9 000 cases and 500 deaths
winnipeg was thought to be at the time
the worst hit
city on the planet the medical world
held its breath at the same time
something else was happening too
progress in pittsburgh dr jonas salk
developed a potential vaccine among the
first to be injected even before
widespread trials his own children this
was his eldest son
at nine years old in 1953. his
laboratory just
one floor above was where the kids were
in iron lungs
we spoke to dr peter salk from his home
in california
he himself is a biomedical researcher
now
one part of canada's involvement in the
development of the vaccine is well known
it was cannot laboratories in toronto
that came up with a way of producing
poliovirus on a massive scale
thousands of liters were shipped to the
u.s salk's lab would kill the virus or
inactivate it so that when it was
injected the body wouldn't get sick
it would create antibodies reporters
grabbed copies of the official statement
after two years of tests involving a
million children the announcement was
made
april 12 1955. the vaccine was safe
and effective but there was a crisis
around the corner
this was probably one of the worst
moments of his life
within two weeks of the vaccine's
rollout vaccinated children
started getting sick in fact they were
turning up
paralyzed usually in the limb where
they'd been injected
now nobody knew if it was a bad batch or
if in fact there was a problem
with the vaccine so the americans
stepped in and stopped the vaccine right
across the country right across the
country
paul martin senior was the canadian
health minister at the time
when the u.s suspended its vaccination
program he was under pressure to do the
same
well martin says his father spoke to his
experts and decided to keep going
if he had stopped in canada that would
have stopped the vaccine in north
america that would that would have
that would have kept the balance as it
turned out martin was right a company in
california had produced a bad batch of
the vaccine
cutter labs hadn't followed the salk
procedure and ended up
injecting children with live polio virus
forty thousand developed a mild form of
the infection
more than 150 were paralyzed permanently
ten died this was a devastating
experience
and there were many many lives that were
altered
dramatically it came to be known as the
cutter incident
the u.s eventually figured out what went
wrong and seeing things were working in
canada
restarted its program it turned out only
to be a temporary setback
in part because of the martin family's
experience
he didn't want another child to miss
getting the vaccine he knew what it
meant to have polio
65 years later as the world looks again
for a vaccine to solve a crisis
the cutter incident is a reminder of the
importance of getting it right
both martin and salk say what their
fathers went through
show reason for caution but also
confidence
the polio vaccine was a solution to a
terrifying disease
a lesson learned for the pharmaceutical
industry and an example of what
science and cooperation can accomplish
this was a great partnership between
canada and the united states between dr
salkin connor
and i'm very proud of the role my father
played
next week on the new reality i don't
understand
how someone dies during a wellness check
frankly along with many canadians
i'm pissed i'm outraged there is a
stigma there is an association that
people have in their minds between
mental health crisis calls and violence
but in the real world it just doesn't
exist
we're talking about peer workers we're
talking about mental health nurses
we're talking about clinicians these are
the folks that we really
want to be a part of our mental health
crisis response teams there's a space in
there for
somebody other than a uniform the new
reality will be back
next saturday i'm donna friesen thanks
for watching
[Music]